in the fight against covet 19 there's a
new fda
warning that the johnson and johnson
vaccine might be linked
to an increased risk of a rare
neurological condition
according to the fda there have been 100
preliminary reports
of guillain-barre beret syndrome and
people who received the single shot
vaccine
95 of those cases required
hospitalization
and one person died to put that in
context more than 12 million
doses of the vaccine have been
administered so far
now johnson johnson says the chance of
having this occur
is very low and we strongly support they
say raising awareness of the signs
and the symptoms of rare events cbs news
medical contributor that's dr
david agus joins us now to discuss david
good morning to you and it's reports
like this
that just freaks people out when they
hear the stories about
the vaccine so put it in context for us
how concerned should people really be
about this report good morning gail
so you know 12.8 million people have
gotten the vaccine and there have been a
hundred cases
unfortunately of guillain-barre syndrome
this is a syndrome dr
guinning dr berea 1916 in france
described it
where people with viral and bacterial
infections can get an autoimmune
reaction against the nerves in their
body
and it happens occasionally with
vaccines it happens with flu vaccine
shingle vaccine to very very rare events
and we're seeing it here
we saw it with the astrazeneca vaccine
also and we're seeing it with the jnj
vaccine
but it is extremely rare and if caught
early can be treated
and managed and so the key is the system
work right the fda
put this on the label people are aware
of it doctors are aware of it
if you have muscle weakness see your
physician we can treat this early
so what exactly does it do i heard you
just say muscle weakness what exactly
happens to you
so you make an immune response not just
against the
vaccine or a virus or a bacteria but you
make it against
a protein that's on your neurons and you
could start to get weakness
in the muscles and that can progress
unless we intervene
and block that immune response
relatively
we know how to do it we have the
treatments for it the key is to identify
it early and with this warning
we will do that so it is safe to get the
vaccine clearly
you can get guillain-barre with covid19
and we see it
much more frequently than with the
vaccine but now that we're aware of it
with the vaccine we'll intervene
and so far we keep hearing that it's
been happening to men over the age of 50
again as you point out it's very very
rare but you know this is the second
thing
about johnson and johnson that has
raised people's eyebrows first we heard
about
possible blood clots what do you say to
people that are really hesitant and
certainly hesitant about the
j j vaccine well we have other vaccines
right there are the rna vaccines a newer
technology not associated as much
with the blood clots or guillain-barre
syndrome as of yet
and so get that the risk of
complications from the virus is
dramatically high
the risk of complications from the
vaccine is extremely rare
we have to be vaccinated and be aware of
any complications we could treat early
but we have to be vaccinated it is one
in a million these complications yeah we
should point out too the reason why the
variants going up is because people are
not vaccinated we have to keep
reminding people you really do need to
get the vaccine dr david agus we thank
you we'll see you again thank you gail